MILITARY, WILL BE FACING A GRAVE
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT, THAT
IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS ARKANSAS
SENATOR TOM COTTON WHO SITS ON
THE ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR.
AS FOR CONTROL OF THE SENATE
COME YOU DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF
THE SENATE AT THIS MOMENT.
GIVEN THE DIRE SITUATION THAT WE
ARE FACING, WHAT CAN AND DO
RIGHT NOW TO ADDRESS WHAT IS A
911 EMERGENCY?
>> LAURA, WE HOPE TO WIN BACK
CONTROL THIS FAULT GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF A LOT OF WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE PENTAGON.
WHETHER IT IS THE FOOLISH AND
WASTED WITCH HUNT LOOKING FOR
SO-CALLED EXTREMISTS OR SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THEY ARE OUTLINED
IN RECRUITING.
I HAVE TAKEN STEPS ALREADY.
EARLIER IN THIS CONGRESS, I
DEMANDED THAT ALL OFFICERS BEING
PROMOTED TO THE GENERAL RANKS
ANSWER A SERIES OF SIMPLE
QUESTIONS, LIKE TO THEY BELIEVE
THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
DECLARATION IS RACIST?
DO THEY BELIEVE SKIN COLOR
SHOULD BE A PRIMARY
CONSIDERATION FOR PROMOTION IN
THE MILITARY?
I SAID IF THEY GET IT WRONG I'M
NOT GOING TO WAVE THEIR
NOMINATION TRUE.
I GOT A LOT OF FEEDBACK FROM THE
OFFICER CORPS THAT HAS FILTERED
DOWN.
THE MESSAGES BEING SENT THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE IN THOSE
POLITICALLY CHARGED ISSUES.
WE NEED A PROFESSIONAL OFFICER
CORPS DOES NOT GET ENGAGED IN
POLITICS IN ANYWAY AND IS
FOCUSED ON THE MILITARY'S SOLE
MISSION WHICH IS FIGHTING AND
WINNING OUR NATION'S WARS.
>> Laura: RIGHT NOW UNLESS YOU
HAVE THE SENATE, THAT YOU HAVE
THE MAJORITY IN THE SENATE,
THERE'S NOTHING.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN A LETTER.
YOU'VE ASKED THE QUESTIONS.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE YOU CAN DO?
LAST TIME I CHECKED FOR EVERY
REPUBLICAN IS VOTING FOR THIS
MASSIVE INCREASE IN MILITARY
SPENDING, GIVEN ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE SEEING OUT THERE THE
PENTAGON.
>> THERE IS MORE THAN WE CAN DO
AS WELL.
IN ADDITION TO THE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
THAT WE PUSH THE SENIOR MILITARY
LEADERS ON THIS QUESTION.
THE ANNUAL DEFENSE BILL.
I VOTED AGAINST THAT THIS YEAR
IN COMMITTEE JUST LIKE I VOTED
AGAINST IT LAST YEAR IN
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I HAD SO MUCH
OF THIS LEFT-WING SOCIAL
ENGINEERING.
NOT JUST GOING TO VOTE FOR
SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY SLAP THIS
ON IT AND I DON'T THINK OUR
TROOPS WANT TO EITHER.
IN THE END, WE WERE ABLE TO
STRIP OUT ALL THOSE PROVISIONS.
I WAS ABLE TO SUPPORT IT IN THE
IMAC.
I HOPE TO DO IT AGAIN THIS YEAR
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR A
BILL THAT FOR INSTANCE REQUIRES
WOMEN TO ENTER THE DRAFT.
SOMETHING THIS MASSIVELY
UNPOPULAR WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO INCLUDE WOMEN IN
AMERICA.
IT'S NOT A JOBS PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT DESIGNED TO ENGAGE IN
SOCIAL ENGINEERING.
IT IS DESIGNED TO FIGHT AND WIN
OUR NATION'S WARS AND AS YOU
OUTLINED AT THE BEGINNING WE
FACE A RECRUITING CRISIS IS AS D
AS IT'S BEEN SINCE VIETNAM.
WE HAVE HAD STRONG ECONOMIES
BEFORE.
SO MANY KIDS WHO MIGHT JOIN THE
ARMY OR THE MARINE CORPS OR NAVY
OR AIR FORCE SEE SOME OF THESE
CONTROVERSIES.
THEY HEAR ABOUT IT AND PEOPLE IN
ACTIVE DUTY AND THEY DECIDE THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO IT RIGHT NOW.
KIDS WHO THINK ABOUT JOINING THE
MILITARY, THEY WANT TO KNOW HOW
TO KILL BAD GUYS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO LEARN HOW TO
USE THE RIGHT PRONOUNS.
>> Laura: TO THAT POINT,
SENATOR.
HERE IS THE AIR FORCE CHIEF OF
STAFF DETAILING ONE OF THEIR
SO-CALLED TOP PRIORITIES.
WATCH.
>> AS TRAGIC AS IT IS, OPENING
UP THE NATION'S CONVERSATION.
THE KEY PART IS NOT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT IT.
USE THE THINGS THAT WE ARE DOING
TO WORK DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
HERE LIVED A RESOURCE THAT PUT
MONEY BEHIND IT.
HAVE LEADERSHIP INVOLVEMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THAT.
>> Laura: SENATOR.
CLIMATE CHANGE, REALLY?
>> THESE ARE NOT THE PRIORITIES
OF AN 18-YEAR-OLD THAT WANTS TO
JOIN THE MILITARY.
>> Laura: OUR MILITARY IS ONE
OF THE MOST DIVERSE INSTITUTIONS
IN AMERICA.
WHEN I STARTED ON ACTIVE DUTY WE
HAD BLACKS, LATINOS, ASIANS,
WHITES.
WHAT MATTERED WAS NOT THE COLOR
OF OUR SKIN.
IT WAS THE RED, WHITE, AND BLUE
THAT WE ALL WORE ON HER
SHOULDER.
WHEN YOU HEAR THIS FROM THESE
LIBERALS WHO WANT TO NEUTER THE
MILITARY YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THAT THE MILITARY IS FULL OF
RACIAL EXTREMISTS, SEXUAL
PREDATORS, THAT IT PRODUCES ALL
OF THESE TRAUMATIZED FRAGILE
EGGSHELLS THAT AMERICA IS NOT A
COUNTRY WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF
AND BE WILLING TO FIGHT FOR, WE
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED THAT
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN ARE
RELUCTANT TO SIGN UP FOR OUR
MILITARY.
>> Laura: THE CIA DIRECTOR
REFERENCE THE ISSUE OF THE
CLIMATE.
WATCH.
>> THE BIGGEST EXISTENTIAL
THREAT IS MANY -- IN MANY WAYS
IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
POLICYMAKERS IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CREATED AS PART OF A NEW MISSION
CENTER.
A UNIT THAT'S FOCUSED ON THESE
ISSUES.
WE HAVE EXPANDED STAFF.
>> Laura: SO THIS IS WHAT OUR
CIA IS PUSHING.
THE AIR FORCE IS PUSHING THAT
DIVERSITY, EQUITY, AND INCLUSION
AGENDA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK CHINA IS
THINKING WATCHING ALL THIS?
CAN THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE THIS
IS THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
>> CHINA IS PROBABLY LAUGHING
THAT UP MAJOR CLINICAL PARTY AND
ITS CHIEF ENEMY WANTS TO
HAMSTRING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION.
IN WHICH WE ARE THE WORLD'S
LEADER AND THEY WANT TO EMPOWER
SO-CALLED GREEN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGY WHICH CHINA IS THE
WORLD'S LEADER OF.
THAT WOULD BE THEIR NATIONAL
STRATEGY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT THE SINGLE
BIGGEST EXISTENTIAL CRISIS THAT
WE FACE.
THE BIGGEST EXISTENTIAL CRISIS
WE FACE IS THAT CHINA WANTS TO
REPLACE US OF THE WORLD
SUPERPOWER AND THEY ARE RAPIDLY
BUILDING UP THEIR NUCLEAR FORCES
THAT MAY ONE DAY OVER MATCH OUR
NUCLEAR FORCES.
THAT IS A REAL EXISTENTIAL
CRISIS.
>> Laura: SENATOR, I HOPE WE
CERTAINLY GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS RECRUITMENT CRISIS IN THE
MILITARY.
FROM THE VACCINE MANDATE TO THE
WOKENESS.
THIS IS ALL